- Et tu as eu..
- Oh putain ya eu un bruit!
*musique stressante*
...
Bien le bonjour à tous, nous sommes actuellement en Lorraine
De retour !
Avec Mamytwink et Zekaria
Hello !
Et François aussi qui été dans les catacombes avec nous
Cette fois on ne va pas dans les catacombes, on va aller dans une sorte d’hôpital abandonné
- Exactement !
- Comment tu appelles ça déjà ?
- Un sanatorium !
- Sanatorium !
- Donc un hôpital qui soignait les gens malades de tuberculose
- Très bien !
- Et cet hôpital là, il a la particularité d'être présumé hanté !
Et là à deux, parce que oui on y va que tout les deux en fait!
Voilà donc on aura juste un talkie-walkie pour être relié à François et Zeka
Qui interviendront en cas de problème
Et puis voilà on a 10 minutes de forêt à traverser avant d'atteindre le sanatorium !
Euh
Vous vouliez une exploration horrifique je crois que vous l'avez,
Et puis on va voir si c'est la panique !
Aller à tout de suite !
*musique stressante*
...
Tu sais où on est ?
Bah en fait j'ai... un peu, euh..
Au pif ?
Non.. un peu tout droit !
Ok, on se rapproche actuellement du lieu
On est juste à côté selon les dires de Florian
On devrait pas tarder à arriver
On aperçoit un bout du lieu
Juste là !
On commence à se rapprocher
WOUAWH !
ON Y EST !
On y est
On y est putain
C'est super grand !
Wow
On est pas les premiers à venir
Non
François tu m'entends ?
Il répond pas ?
Non il répond pas
Putain...
Je vais juste checker si on a du réseau au cas où
Ouais c'est bon full barres
Ok
On va visiter les étages déjà
Aller, allons-y fonçons
Et le reflet...
moi ce qui me fait peur pour le moment
C'est le reflet de nos lumières dans les vitres
Ouais
Ça me fait super peur, j'sais pas pourquoi je...
J'suis pas bien, bon aller avançons !
Outlast 2 irl !
Exactement !
Ici ça devait être une cuisine
Une cuisine ?
De l’hôpital
Putain...
C'est les toilettes ça ?
Douche
Ça c’était les douches
Y'a encore une bassine quoi
Ah voilà c'est par ici
Les escaliers
Ici tu as encore l'ascenseur
L'ascenseur qui est encore là
Il marche juste plus trop quoi
Putain..
Ok, on va commencer à monter
Combien d'étages ?
J'crois qu'il y a... 4 étages
4 étages ?
C'est super grand quoi !
Y'a une ouverture de porte
Ouais
Le truc se ferme derrière nous
C'est vraiment ça qui nous...
Wouaaw !
Putain !
T'imagines on voit un mec à la fenêtre ?
C'est très silencieux pour le moment y'a aucun bruits bizarres
C'est vrai que pour le moment ici c'est....
Mais c'est...
Mais c'est pas pour autant que...
Que j'suis serein en faite
C'est pas pour autant que j'suis serein
Parce que euh...
Je sais très bien qu'à un moment il va y avoir un bruit
Et vu qu'on aura fait 20 minutes de silence
Il va nous effrayer...
Tu veux continuer à monter ?
Y'a un truc sympa à voir..
Putain...
Wouaw
Qu'est ce que c'était que ça ?
Alors, je pense que c'était ici qu'on venait...
Qu'on venait nettoyer le linge en faite
Le linge ?
C'est ma seule thérorie...
Wouah c'est de la machinerie ici
C'est de la grosse machinerie
C'est de la grosse machinerie...
Ce serait cool de voir la machinerie de l'ascenseur
Euuh...Ouais...Je...
J'crois qu'on... la voit dans le grenier
Dans le grenier ?
Donc pour information c'est un lieu qu'a été abandonné
Y'a maintenant...11 années
C'est ça ouais
Donc il est quand même assez vieux
Fin j'veux dire ça fait...
assez longtemps, par exemple celui au Japon j'crois que c'était y'a...
7 ans, 8 ans j'crois qu'il a été abandonné fin bref...
D'accord
Tu vois qu'en 11 ans...
Bah ça se dégrade un truc de ouf quoi putain...
On va se diriger dans la deuxième aile, voir ce qu'il y a...
Tu veux dire quelques choses ?
J'était en train de te raconter rapidement l'histoire du lieu
Ouais
On est dans un ancien sanatorium
Donc c'est ici qu'ils venaient en faite...
soigner des gens...
malade de tuberculose...
au début du XXe siècle puisque cet hôpital en faite il date de 1902
1902 !
Donc il a plus de 100 ans...
Putain...
Et ils l'ont construit parce qu'à l'époque la tuberculose c'était...
une des plus grandes causes de mortalités
Y'avait 20% des morts c'était des gens qui mourraient de tuberculose c'était une...
c'était une maladie pulmonaire...
Ouais c'est terrible ça...
Et donc ils devaient regrouper les gens qui avaient la tuberculose dans un hôpital pour éviter la contagion quoi...
et surtout pour les soigner...
A grande échelle quoi
avec euh...
une cure été basée sur de l'air frais...
De l'air frais ?
parce que au début du XXe siècle c'était l'industrialisation ...
donc il y avait énormément d'usines...
et... y'avait un exode rural, tout le monde allait en ville pour trouver du travail...
Ouais
du coup les villes étaient ultras polluées c'était...
les conditions d'hygiène étaient très mauvaises et donc ça favorisait le développement de la tuberculose...
et donc on créér des hôpitaux un peu à l'écart dans la campagne...
ici on est en hauteur, on surplombe la vallée
J'ai une anecdote
J'ai une sœur de ma grand mère qui est morte de la tuberculose
Ah sérieux ?
Ouais...
Son copain qui lui a refilé et... bah c'était y'a longtemps du coup, très longtemps...
et elle est morte de ça quoi...
il lui avait scillé les côtes je crois  , je sais plus pour faire quoi mais...
Sérieux ?
Ouais ouais...
et il avait dû lui scillé t'sais c'était à l'époque, tu sais y...
mais même y'a pas si longtemps que ça en faite tu vois, on était pas des ouf en science comme maintenant et...
Tu sais qu'aujourd'hui c'est encore dans le monde une des maladies qui tue le plus sauf que dans notre pays...
elle n'existe quasiment plus parce qu'on vit plus dans les conditions si précaire
Ils ont décidé que les plus pauvres ne devaient pas payer pour être soignés...
D'accord
mais ceux qui avaient les moyens pouvaient payer...
et donc ceux qui payaient été au premier et deuxième étage avec la belle vue...
Ouais ?
et ceux qui n'avaient pas les moyens de payer ils étaient logés dans le grenier
Ils étaient soignés mais ils avaient pas une belle vue ouais
Donc on va pas faire la partie... des riches hein ceux qui avaient la belle vue...
parce que c'est exposé... sur des habitations en faite y'a des gens qui peuvent nous voir...
et ont a pas envie de mettre fin à cette exploration... car la police débarque
Du coup ont se dirigent vers...
Le grenier...
Le grenier !
Ah c'est une vraie entrée de grenier quoi
Ouais
Ah c'est... t'as pas blagué c'est le vrai grenier quoi
C'est le vrai grenier
Ouais le vrai grenier
Putain...
Je pense que c'est le mécanisme...
Ah bah voilà de l'ascenseur il est là
On en parlait
Putain
C'est clair que t'étais...
t'étais mieux quand t'avais de l'argent quand même putain
Ouais
Je trouve ça beau d'avoir prit la décision de soigner gratuitement les gens qui avaient pas l'argent pour...
pour payer leurs soins quoi
Puis aujourd'hui avec la sécurité sociale on a un peu ça toujours
Oui parce qu'à l'époque y'avait pas de sécurité sociale
A l'époque y'avait pas de sécu
Là-bas y'avait une sorte de... d'observatoire
Ouais, tu as une vue magnifique
J'vais éteindre ma lampe
Mais en gros ici...
tu pouvais te poser et admirer la ville...et la vallée
Bon de pleine nuit on voit pas grand chose mais...
Au début du XXe siècle...
Y'avait pas tout ça
au loin tu avais les usines, l'épaisse fumée...
à 20 kilomètres d'ici, on était en Allemagne en faite...
parce que...
à la fin de la guerre de 1870-71...
l'Allemagne avait annexé une grande partie de la Moselle, l'Alsace et une petite partie de la Meurthe...
et donc ici on était en territoire français et il y avait eu un immense exode de français qui voulaient pas devenir allemands...
qui s'est donc cassés pour venir dans le coin et tu as eu la popula...
Oh putain
Y'a eu un bruit
putain l'anti stress ...
Y'a eu un bruit frère
Aah putain...
Après tu sais on est sur les toits mec
Ouais ouais
Je pense qu'ici les oiseaux y doivent se régaler quoi
On va redescendre en bas...
on va voir les chambres de riches ?
Yes
Ok
Descend vite
Merci, merci à toi qui a mis ce message qui nous met en confiance
Putain tu m'as fait peur
C'était les douches...
Ouais c'était les... les douches communes
Ah le caca de souris
Quoi ?
C'est ça qui me fait peur moi des cacas de souris
T'as peur des cacas de souris ?
Ah oui parce que t'as peur des souris
C'est un lieu réputé le plus hanté de la région quoi
Ouais il a la réputation d'être hanté...
qu'on puisse y voir des...
des phénomènes comme des apparitions de silhouettes, d'orbes ou PVE c'est...
je sais pas ce que c'est...
PVE c'est Players Versus...
T'as des articles de presses sur euh...
Ah ouais ?
Qui dise que le lieu à la réputation d'être hanté
Bah nous on les...
On les attirent pas trop quoi...
En même temps c'est vrai que... c'est très calme
La caméra est en place, y'a plus qu'à attendre...
et voir si on entend quelques choses
Ecoutez... y'a aucun bruit suspect, c'est plutôt tranquille
Mais on va aller dans la cave...
du lieu
Wow
C'est l'entrée de la cave
Bienvenue en enfer
Putain...
"Welcome in Hell"
Wow
Putain c'est super grand
La porte qui a été condamnée...
Elle a été condamnée ?
Ouais, tu sais ça me fait un peu penser au mode zombie dans Call of Duty où tu condamnes les portes, les fenêtres pour éviter que les zombies... puissent passer
Putain merde pourquoi elle a été condamnée
Je sais pas
T'as entendu un bruit ?
Ouais vas-y viens
Ah oui j'ai cru entendre aussi mec
C'était peut-êtres les gouttes d'eaux
Ouais
Ouais j'ai entendu tout à l'heure quelqu'un marcher
Nan, on a fait le tour du lieu on va maintenant devoir retraverser la forêt
Ça c'est finalement je pense... c'est ça le plus gros
Ouais en faite moi je... je t'ai dit j'angoisse des forêts je... ça me fait angoisser
parce que t'as un sentiment d'impuissance qui est exceptionnelle, tu vois ?
T'as une visibilité de merde, y'a un milliard de bruit autour de toi, si y'a un vrai bruit d'un mec qui marche tu sauras pas le...
Ah non c'est bon
Bon voilà
J'ai entendu des bruissements
Traversons, rejoignons nos amis
Ouais c'est bon
C'est bon ?
Ah les voilà
Ouais ça va
Ça a été ?
Le François !
François de retour !
Ça s'est bien passé ?
Ouiii
Nickel
Oh ils font un feu en nous attendant, on va jouer à Hearthstone autour du feu
Ça se met bien ? En nous attendant ?
Un petit feu histoire de se réchauffer, avec un petit réflecteur histoire de pas avoir froid
Et on est bien
Putain c'est vrai que ça chauffe là !
Et on est grave bien
C'est fini !
C’était impressionnant comme lieu parce qu'en plus il est...
il est en altitude et il est aussi... le lieu lui même est en hauteur un peu comme l’hôtel qu'on a fait au Japon...
C'est assez fou du coup t'as le décor du grenier, le décor des pièces, le décor de la cave c'est trois ambiances très différentes
L'allée et le retour c'était très dur pour moi parce que j'ai très très peur des forêts en pleine nuit ça me terrifie
Le challenge ça va être de... dans une prochaine vidéo de passer une nuit entière dans une forêt
N'hésitez pas à nous dire si l'idée vous plaît
Hésitez pas à aimé la vidéo si elle vous a plu comme d'habitude et à passer voir la chaîne  de ce monsieur qui s'appelle Mamytwink
qui fait d'autres explorations, pleins d'ailleurs essentiellement sans moi du coup on en a fait que deux ensemble sur un total de
Sur une trentaine
Sur une trentaine donc vous en avez 28 à rattraper, aller les voir, au revoir !
Au revoir François !
Salut !
Zek et tout là
Aller salut !